when are you gonna start wrestling
this seemed like it was a thing this was
to seemed like a thing that might have
happened you was popping off on some of
these wrestlers online that was coming
on Twitter I forgot who you were going
at it with too I mean me too I forgot I
don't even know these people that was
coming at me but shout out to Stone Cold
I just missed Stone Cold he was a legend
nice guy I used to watch me growing up I
was one stone cold to Stun Me pause like
I'd be like bro hit me with the stunner
bro look he's behind you on the poster
no he was Legend he a legend for show
I'd be like bro hit me with the stunner
bro let me [__] slam the beers and
then Stun Me for tick tock are you a
legend for self shout out to Stone Cold
Steve Austin will you have you did you
see Snoop wrestling yeah cease fire and
Snoop was out there like you know he's
done the aw thing I mean I'm not against
it you know what I'm saying
I'd rather box though like I'm sorry
about the hop in the Box you do like
some Floyd Mayweather celebrity boxing
yeah why did you and uh Chris Brown ever
fight I don't know it seemed like that
was really close to happening at a
certain point in time and I don't know
but [__] we need to promote more
positivity anyway that's a good thing we
ain't fighting I mean I'm saying that
was my brother you know I'm saying like
at the point of time you know I'm saying
I always like Chris Brown music I always
rock with him so I felt like that whole
[__] was just some [__] anyway you
know what I'm saying right I just seen
him plenty times since then would you um
but would you do like you know we see a
lot of artists now getting paid like
High purse money to actually go do a
real yeah I'm knocking [__] out give me
the bag I'm in there so you're like you
know participate maybe like uh you know
blue faces fighting ddgs fighting
there's a lot of rappers who are not I'm
not talking about fighting on some
negative [__] they're boxing getting
paid that's hard would you fight
blueface man I'll fight anybody for the
bag anybody yeah blue faces he's got
reached though he's a tall guy I don't
matter who it is put me in the Rings
whatever the bag
has to uh he probably gets a lot of
practice dodging because he's living
with Krishan you know and I feel like
she's a shout out to her I ain't got
nothing to do with that hey
um how cool was it to do verses Man and
during a pandemic I feel like your your
verses was like one of the cooler ones
because it kind of represented like an
era that really hadn't been like tapped
into yet for verses
um it was lit you know what I'm saying
shout out to Bow Wow you feel me like I
used to watch him before I got into the
game growing up and stuff like that so
to you know get in the game do my thing
and then do a versus with him it was
like full circle moment you Families how
hard or how much effort did you put into
like putting the playlist together
because that was kind of the hardest
part about verses sometimes people would
they wouldn't have to order songs right
you know what I'm saying like did you
put a lot of thought in like yeah I had
to uh talk to the fans you know what I'm
saying I've sent out a couple tweets and
looked it up with the fast head it
looked you know just thought about the
tours well the best reaction from tours
you know what I'm saying just the vibe
you know it was just a whole vibe
putting putting together that show I
feel like it came out it came out nice I
got a lot of uh good comments and
feedback from that verses did you bring
out Sammy during that
Sammy did he come on dude kiss me to the
phone I'm not I can't remember I brought
out French I brought French out about uh
who else I brought up I brought a couple
people out I can't remember I don't know
if Sammy was there I think he was I
can't remember I don't know for sure
yeah you and Bow Wow have definitely had
some moments together right you guys had
some the touring [__] and the verses
he's kind of like the original kid
rapper crisscross was but he's kind of
like the original kid rapper you know
yeah nah that's what's up like he
definitely you know what I'm saying was
doing his thing like as a young kid he
definitely had like all the shorties
like tweaking like when we was in school
everybody was like
tripping off about a while for so
Mother's Day Sunday what do you do for
the baby mom and then for the mom mom
man
um
just something nice like you know
whatever they want to do something
special you know what I'm saying no
surprises you're just like hey what do
you want let's go do that we surprised
him but we wouldn't do what they want to
do too you know what I'm saying do you
bring the The Gangs together like do you
have your mom kick it with the baby mom
um
because how many times you only have one
kid or do you have multiple children I
just have one yeah you just have one
yeah and you just had you just had your
one too yeah so you know it's gonna be
like everything's still new by the way
kudos to you for making it this far
without any kids until recently if if I
I would have never have guessed you only
had one kid yeah I mean see it was time
you know what I'm saying I'm I'm getting
up there now okay if I gotta leave my
legacy behind man I love it man is it do
you think having a kid changed you
yeah for sure you know you like start
kind of like
you know you got to kind of run
everything through a filter now like
damn I got a kid to come home to you
that too and then just like just my
schedule you know what I'm saying
because before I could just you know
work all day do what I want now I gotta
make time for them too yeah what I'm
saying so that's dope man
try to uh Soulja Boy for being a dad a
good dad at that yeah yeah
he he uh he just turned eight months he
crawling a little bit oh yeah you're
definitely you got to be changing
diapers bro you gotta get your hands
dirty bruh nah a little bit a little
something a little something like that
yeah a little something sold your car
hopefully coming soon
hey [__] Elon Musk bro Soldier Boy bruh
what we like Elon nah man no we can't
get no [__] Tesla we got to get a
soldier card right Elon Musk Elon I love
you Elon I'm playing I do too I'm trying
I don't know what he's talking about I
just test drove
we big Tesla game big Tesla game that's
what's up man so yo go get the album
right now Soldier season go buy some
clothes so I was just season out right
now go get it buy a [__] video game
Walmart man big Draco glad to see that
the thing with you and NBA young boy's
not a real thing
yeah it's all good man just it was just
it just so happened to drop album on the
same day a little internet exchange
which you've done millions of times all
the time you're the king you are the
internet exchange King for sure man they
know what's up man it's Draco sauce man
they know what they know what's going on
there it is my guy I appreciate you
pulling up brother yes sir fire